si es efectivamente esta medida el
proporcionar una salida para más de 8000
inmigrantes que han llegado a la
frontera de ceuta y la han cruzado hacia
el territorio español es una medida de
fuerza de presión del ejecutivo marroquí
primero en represalia al gobierno de
pedro sánchez por haber aceptado la
propuesta del gobierno de argelia con
quien mantiene marruecos serias
diferencias por lo que es el territorio
todavía en disputa del sáhara exagera
español sáhara occidental ocupado por
marruecos desde 1975 entonces por haber
recibido españa al presidente y al líder
máximo del frente polisario saharaui
porque está enfermo y infectado con kobe
19 está en un hospital de españa
entonces en esa medida de represalia
ordenó no vigilar la lava ya no vigilar
la frontera con ceuta para que así
hubiese una andanada un flujo muy masivo
de personas incluso niños familias con
bebés que han cruzado por las playas de
ceuta en territorio español pero es
también una medida de fuerza para
obligar a españa' y presionarla para que
acepte la marroquinidad
la que fuera otrora una colonia española
en un gesto que imita lo que hizo el
presidente de trump antes de terminar su
mandato en el mes de diciembre pasado
ahora susana que ocurrirá con estas
personas alrededor de 4.800 migrantes ya
fueron devueltos de manera inmediata por
el ejército español pero qué pasará con
los que continúan en territorio europeo
principalmente los menores de edad
bueno son los famosos mena sobre los que
también se ha hablado mucho en la
campaña por ejemplo reciente por lo que
es la presidencia de la comunidad de
madrid' entonces yo creo que el
ejecutivo de sánchez lo que va a
intentar es llegar a acuerdos con las
autoridades marroquíes para devolver a
estas personas a la mayor cantidad
posible de inmigrantes mientras tanto
estarán a la espera en albergues o en
centros de acogida para migrantes y
refugiados que españa tiene mucha
experiencia en este tipo de situaciones
pero claramente es una cifra inusitada
la que han cruzado cruzaron en el
espacio de 48 horas 8 mil personas 4800
como tú dices ya han emprendido incluso
voluntariamente el regreso pero otras
tendrán que volver a su lugar de origen
que es marruecos pero no olvidemos que
también hay subsaharianos personas a las
que habrá que indagar habrá que ver qué
tipo de nacionalidad qué tipo de
documentos traen y ver si se pueden
devolver a sus países de origen
hablabas de algún tipo de acuerdos entre
el gobierno español y marroquí para
lograr que estas personas sean devueltas
qué tipo de cuadros y qué tipo de
acuerdos podrían llegar
bueno efectivamente marruecos como
también lo ha hecho en el pasado libia
con italia o con la propia unión europea
siempre utilizan la válvula de escape de
la migración porque saben que de esta
manera presionan al gobierno de turno
pero como indica sánchez la frontera de
ceuta además de ser frontera con españa
también es frontera con europa y yo creo
que lo que está desvelando esta falta de
sintonía con el gobierno de marruecos es
realmente un compromiso para ver de qué
manera se frena esta inmigración que
luego tildamos en la prensa española por
ejemplo europea de clave destina pues
sabemos que hay miles de personas que
quieren cruzar los acuerdos seguramente
vayan por el lado de presionar por parte
de marruecos a españa sobre todo a nivel
de diplomacia de los reyes felipe se
estimó a hamás el sexto para que ambos
tengan un compromiso respecto de no
seguir insistiendo en el referéndum para
los saharauis que es lo que quisiera
naciones unidas- y lo que vienen
exigiendo los propios saharauis pero
claro sin que este referéndum esté
viciado por los colonos marroquíes que
han sido trasladados durante décadas que
dura el conflicto al territorio saharaui
así de susana complicado este conflicto
además de histórico gracias por
explicarnos un poco
entender un poco más lo que ocurre en
esta región entre europa y áfrica